Now there's just one last thing we need
to take care of in our data model,
deletion rules.
What are deletion rules?
Well, let me ask you this,
what happens to all the notes in a
notebook when this notebook is deleted?
And what happens to the notebook
when a note inside it is deleted?
These questions can be resolved
setting deletion rules.
Let's start with the Notes property.
The deletion rules are over here,
and we have several options.
No Action, which is usually not
something that you want to use,
Nullify, Cascade, and Deny.
Deny is also something that
you usually don't use.
So, our common options are Nullify and
Cascade.
When we delete a notebook,
what should we do to the notes?
They should be deleted also.
That's what cascade means.
When notebook is deleted,
all the linked notes will go away.
So this should be Cascade.
And we need to do the same thing for
the inverse relationship.
What happens to the notebook
when one note is deleted?
Should we delete the notebook?
Obviously not.
What we should do is remove
the reference that that notebook had to
this note.
That is what Nullify does.
One last warning before we move on.
Getting your deletion rules wrong is one
of the most common beginner mistakes.
If you set Cascade on both
relationships your app will crash.
We'll talk about that later.
So pause this video now, and
set up your deletion rules now as well.
And that's it,
we're done setting up the model.
And from now on it's going to
be pretty smooth sailing.